what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and we just watched the
moon night finale and boy was it a great
finale but it does seem like there's a
little bit of division on this so i want
you to let me know right away what you
thought about the finale in the comments
down below rate it one out of ten i
loved it let me know what you think
there was a lot to unpack in this
episode specifically at the very very
end so we're gonna do a quick recap of
all the important things you need to
know about this episode and then talk
about that ending and explain everything
you need to know including
whether or not konshu is actually gone
or is he simply manipulating mark and
stephen and we gotta talk about jake
lockley so a lot to talk about in this
video let's jump right into it and of
course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos okay so moon knight
episode six pretty much picks up where
episode four left off actually when
harrow shot mark spector and he died
harrow and his men pull mark's body out
of the water so they can grab ahmed's
ushapti now hero has everything that he
needs to release ahmed and his staff
even changes instead of having two
crocodile heads which represent the head
of ahmet which is a crocodile head it
now has only one and the other side has
turned into an axe and his cain has
actually gotten a lot longer here as
well turning more into like a staff so
hero and his men leave to the great
pyramid of giza which we find out later
now something important to notice is
that hero actually leaves the scarab on
mark's body now as we know the scarab is
actually a compass that points to ahmed
tsubhapti so leila after kind of saying
her goodbyes to mark picks up the scarab
and knows exactly where harrow is
because of the compass now we
immediately see that hero actually has
more power now that he has the ashapti
on his way to the great pyramid of giza
he is stopped by the egyptian patrol
agency and hero knows that he now has
greater power so he gets out not
worrying about all of the guns pointing
at him and he automatically starts using
his power to judge people and all of
them actually die but one of them now
remember they're being judged
prematurely some of them might not have
even committed the so-called sin that
will condemn them to a bad judgment but
only one is left and he is deemed a good
man by arthur now layla actually managed
to sneak onto one of arthur's trucks her
plan now since mark and the abilities of
kanchu and moon knight are gone is to
simply sneak up on him and stab him to
death but the egyptian goddess towerette
interferes by communicating with her
through dead bodies and she relays to
her that mark could actually return
however layla thinks that she can still
do it on her own so she continues to
follow harrow now if you actually notice
during the scene harrow seems kind of
uneasy and it seems to be at first that
he kind of knows that layla's there
however i think it's something different
i think that he knows he's about to come
face to face with ahmet and he knows
that his scales are unbalanced obviously
we've seen this scene play out and he
thinks that he's going to be judged and
probably killed so this is probably why
he seems a little uneasy here back to
that in a bit we then get inside of the
chamber of the gods and the great
pyramid of giza quite possibly one of
the most annoying scenes in the mcu the
avatars and their gods have felt a
disturbance and even at first some of
the gods don't really know what's up
until the avatar of hawthor says someone
is trying to release ahmed and this is
super frustrating because if they would
have just taken at least one minute to
investigate what konchu and mark were
saying in the very beginning this could
have all been avoided like literally
just could have taken one minute to
investigate the accusation instead of
simply just trusting the person that is
being accused of trying to release an
evil god and of course it's too late
haro shows up and defeats all of the
avatars and we find out that the only
thing you actually need to do to release
these gods is simply breakthrough shakti
so harrow breaks through shabti of ahmed
and she is released and she actually
looks pretty freaking cool meanwhile
layla is looking for the ushabti of
kanchu so she can release him now what's
really interesting here is that ahmed
doesn't actually know who hero is she
literally asks to whom do i owe my
gratitude so this actually answers a
question that a lot of people have had
it seems that amit didn't actually give
the staff to hero he somehow happened
upon it he did say it was given to her
first avatar which clearly is not him
because we see him become her avatar
which means the power that he had was
simply inside of the staff that came
from amit now you gotta give it to hero
he truly does believe in everything that
he's doing he accepts that he probably
is going to die and even when ahmed
fights him and says no you should be my
avatar he actually says that there are
other people out there who worship and
follow her who have balance scales so
crazy credit to where crazy credit is
due he practices what he preaches and he
truly does believe in what he is trying
to do despite the fact that it's going
to kill probably billions of people
meanwhile layla manages to release
konchu and he tries to get her to be his
avatar but she actually sees through his
manipulative ways and says no so he
bails meanwhile ahmet says let's go
cleanse the souls of cairo essentially
let's go judge everybody and probably
kill most of the people but then we pick
up where the last episode left off mark
is in the field of reeds and steven is
left behind in the sand frozen and
what's interesting here is it's not an
actual true paradise towerette says that
he made it he's essentially in heaven
and that he has no worries anymore but
he does how could he ever truly have
peace knowing that stephen was back
there in the sand he wouldn't actually
ever have peace this would never
actually be paradise for him so he goes
back to stephen who happened to be
frozen in sand right in front of the
gate of osiris he delivers a very
heartwarming speech and eventually after
he turns to sand glass as well the two
of them are resurrected their souls go
back to the shot up body and conscious
powers wrapped them up in the moon
knight robes and they are healed and
they are ready to go to battle but not
before they renegotiate the deal with
konchu and although they do work out a
new deal it is not what they think it is
and we're about to talk about that in
just a sec now before mark and steven
actually go back to the body konchu
actually tries to stop ahmed himself and
they have a very awesome god fight it
gets even more awesome when they both
become insanely large and fight in egypt
but the whole gods fighting gods is
pretty cool meanwhile the avatar of
osiris tells layla that they need more
avatars but he tells her that they need
to trap her inside of a body not a
statue she'll be more vulnerable so
layla decides to become an avatar
herself towerette takes over and a new
egyptian hero is born which i'm about to
talk about in just a second and fully
explain so now ahmet is released and her
followers have so much more power now it
seems like any follower of amit has the
ability to judge somebody as amit along
with hero has placed scales on
everybody's arms and of course they're
being judged and there are a lot of what
ahmet would call bad people out there so
they die and their apparent souls feed
ahmet and make her even stronger as she
grows to be the size of the great
pyramid of giza itself now leila all of
a sudden has the powers of towerette by
being her avatar she gets her own suit
as well and it looks ridiculously
awesome and what this hero basically is
is the scarlet scarab from marvel comics
but with a little twist now in the
comics it's actually her father abdel
fal who is the scarlet scarab eventually
he would go on to pass down the mantle
to his son but it is kind of cool how
the mcu changed this a bit now in the
comics the scarlet scarab gets his
powers from the ruby scarab and that's
something they clearly changed in the
mcu here layla clearly gets her powers
from towerette being her avatar but if
you notice there are actually some
similarities in the costumes and if you
look right below her neck you can
actually see a scarab now the costumes
are obviously a little bit different
because the scarlet scarab is a man in
the comics and layla is obviously a
woman but if you look at the part around
her neck that is extremely similar and
if you look at the parts on her wrist
those are extremely similar as well and
overall this outfit looks amazing and
she has wings and is the first egyptian
superhero in the mcu and that's super
super cool and she means some serious
business when she flies in to save mark
steven she kicks arthur and then when he
goes to hit her with a blast she
deflects it back and knocks him back way
down now obviously moon knight shows up
and he starts to battle arthur but only
it's not just moon night now and it's
not just mark they're all kind of
working together moon knight mr knight
mark and steven and when they fight
together it's really really cool to see
them switch back and forth now
eventually ahmet after trying to get
konshu to join her and kind of roll at
her side in which she says no eventually
kind of defeats konchu and eventually
arthur kind of defeats mark stephen and
layla however there is another rescuer
here right as layla and mark were about
to die mark's eyes roll back he blacks
out and he wakes up and everyone with
the exception of hero is dead but
harrow's pretty much dead he's on the
brink of dying mark immediately goes
that wasn't you was it steven layla even
asks what the heck happened and mark
says i blacked out and of course as we
know this was jake lockley he was
revealed in the mid credits scene and
we're about to talk about him a lot but
to finish off the important parts that
you need to know and the recap of the
episode layla and mark take hero's body
back to the chamber of the gods along
with his staff and they end up binding
ahmet to harrow's body which renders her
powerless
now khan shoot tells mark to end him in
tarot and in turn end ahmet but mark is
done doing conscie's work he says do it
yourself and also release me that was
the deal so he releases him but we soon
find ourselves back at the psychiatric
ward and steven and mark are meeting
with dr harrow again but right away
notice that stephen and mark are still
working together they're still in sync
they're a little confused at first but
they see blood coming from harrow's foot
and mark even says hey you see that
don't you and steven says oh yeah i see
it and harrow is actually quite confused
he asks why he's bleeding now this is a
call back to the very first scene of
moon knight where hero breaks up glass
puts it in his shoes and walks on them
but mark and steven realize that this is
all in their head and they choose to
wake up and the big thing to take away
here is that it looks like both of them
have equal control over the body they
have accepted that they are a part of
each other and they're going to live the
rest of their lives with each other so
they're working together however and
unfortunately there is a third
personality inside of mark stephen and
we are introduced to this person in the
post credit scene and that person is
jake lockley we've been talking about
him for a couple of episodes now he's
kind of popped up when mark and stephen
go unconscious and they realize that
neither of them had control over the
body but the body has committed murder
that was jake lockley and jake lockley
clearly doesn't really have much of a
conscience this is a different side to
mark and there's a lot to digest here
now it looks like mark and layla kind of
took a page out of the book of mark and
steven's head and they put arthur harrow
in a psychiatric ward and they keep him
medded up and restrained there so that
ahmed could never get out but that way
they don't actually have to kill arthur
however a mysterious person speaking
spanish manages to kidnap arthur and he
puts him in a limo where we see konchu
and notice konchi was actually dressed
in a suit much like steven grant's mr
knight was it looks like kancho actually
liked that look and has somewhat adapted
it for himself now when arthur sees
konchu he laughs and says you can't hurt
us notice he says us because ahmet is
now sealed to him however we didn't know
how manipulative kanchu actually was for
example he expresses that mark truly
believed that after he and konchu parted
ways he would go after laila his wife
kanchu acts like this was funny but he
did actually threaten mark with this in
previous episodes he would say stuff
like may i remind you who i want as my
next avatar he said that in episode 2
implying that he was actually going to
make layla his avatar but that was just
konchu being manipulative to try and get
mark and steven to do what he wanted
because here we are introduced to mark's
third alter jake lockley the ruthless
man who has been killing the entire time
when mark and stephen didn't know who it
was and he is ruthless if you notice in
the psychiatric hospital which is the
seikai witch psychiatric hospital jake
actually killed a bunch of the workers
so he could get arthur out of there and
these are very very innocent people but
he doesn't care at all he kills them
just to get what he wants nothing stands
in his way including arthur harrow and
ahmet conscious says mark has no idea
how troubled he truly is and he
introduces jake and jake kills arthur
and ahmet and this actually answers a
question that i had because in episode 3
konchu was there with mark and stephen
when the alter ego took over who they
didn't know at the time killed everybody
konchu said nothing but he saw it all
and he clearly knew that it was neither
of the two but now we know that it was
jake lockley the entire time and it
seems like konchu has a lot of control
over jake lockley now the big question
that a lot of people are probably
wondering and that i've been asked a lot
last night is did konchu really leave
mark and stephen and the answer to this
is no he still basically has control
over their bodies however they don't
know it because they aren't really aware
of jake lockley i'm sure they are aware
that somebody else killed those people
but they definitely have no idea that
konchu is still using that third alter
ego as his avatar and since they all
share the same body and since mark is
actually the original person that means
that mark and therefore stephen is still
the avatar for konchu konchi was simply
hiding it from them because it turns out
he is a manipulative jerk but this is
kind of good news because the moon
knight series was awesome and the
introduction of jake lockley and konchu
still being there means that we have a
lot of unanswered questions for the
future of moon knight but it looks like
they are going to answer them since they
did introduce jake and remember there
are a lot of things coming up for marvel
and with doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness they are
definitely introducing a more occult
side a more darker side of the mcu which
means there's plenty of room for moon
knight and blade and deadpool and the
midnight suns to come in and at this
point it does look like they have set up
a season two for moon night despite
whatever they may have said before i am
now fully expecting a season two for
moon night which is great because this
season was fantastic but let me know
what you think in the comments down
below and of course i'll be doing more
videos breaking down more things about
the finale of moon night soon be sure to
rate the finale in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
of course subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all the latest mcu news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof